at the end of the day much like cyber
security by the way
it's always a balance between um
being 100 secure for example taking your
phone and putting it in a bucket of
water
in that point it's secure right it's
completely secure but it's also not
usable
so there's this balance between security
and usability
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media
partnership with ctec welcome to 20
minute leaders today i am joined by one
of the cyber security leaders of the
world
meet omari lavi the co-founder and ceo
of orchestra group
omaree is a serial entrepreneur and an
angel investor he co-founded nso group
and is the co-founder and ceo of
orchestra group a holistic cyber
security platform for proactive cyber
defense
omri founded several technology
companies in various fields
specializing in enterprise sw telecom
cyber intelligence and cyber security
he is also the co-founder at founders
group a private investment firm which
invests in early-stage startups
he is an active philanthropist
continuously supporting numerous
non-profits in education
cancer wellness elderly and child care
omri lavi welcome to 20 minute leaders
all the way from new jersey how are you
i'm well how are you i'm doing great
i've heard your name
way too many times over the over the
last few years
it is no secret that you are one of the
founders of nso group which has been
a source in the media and that that a
lot of people have been have been
talking about and
from my background in 8200 obviously a
fascinating aspect of the cyber security
space
you founded multiple companies most
recently now co-founded
a orchestra group and and working with
with big companies to to figure out how
how the hell do you even start thinking
about cyber security in in a greater
spectrum
and and and you're going to you're going
to say that you know what your
co-founder calls it in a second so
that's going to be a lot of fun
but what i'd love to spend these 20
minutes is going a little bit over your
journey
the different companies you founded the
milestones and your
your understanding of the market and
leadership and innovation through that
and then talking a little bit more
broadly about orchestra and how you're
dealing with cyber security in the world
and i've spoken enough um
tell me a little bit about yourself sure
so happy to so first of all
thanks for having me over uh it's uh
hopefully going to be a lot of fun uh so
i'm as you said i'm
willa v i'm 40 years old i'm a serial
entrepreneur
i founded probably over half a dozen
different companies
and i invested in in dozens more
over the last uh 15 years of of my
career
i think i probably most known for
my involvement and being the co-founder
of nso group who
is one of the largest cyber intelligence
companies in the world today
uh i still hold a position of director
in that company
but i also founded founders group
together with some of my partners um
who who is a small investment group uh
we've done
over 40 different investments in the
last decade
uh all from our own capital uh we
don't uh deploy fund capital it's all
it's all funded by
us and the uh and the amazing partners
around it
um all of our investments were in tech
obviously uh i would say the majority
are in cyber security and cyber
intelligence
uh which is where we feel uh most at
home despite
the fact that none of us is from 8200
uh so you know wow it's the anomaly
yes yes it kind of proves the theory you
don't have to be from 8200
uh or with a degree in computer science
to uh
to make it in in tech um and so we're
going to start
there because you were a combat soldier
and how do you find yourself
being how do you find yourself being one
of the top cyber security experts in the
world
well first of all thank you for the
compliment i i wouldn't go it doesn't
make sense to me
uh it doesn't make sense to me either i
also wouldn't go that far i know from
the
one of the top cyber security experts in
the world but i i know my way of
creating one of the biggest changes and
one of the biggest impacts through your
organization so it is
as far as i'm concerned the statement
holds oh thank you so much
um i i'll be honest with you i think um
you know there's a lot of very
intelligent capable people in israel and
everywhere in the world and people are
sometimes um
lack the ability to dare me and chalev
when we founded
nso um despite
everybody telling us that it's
completely crazy um
despite not having the right background
not having the right connections
um we thought there was a good
opportunity it actually started from a
different company that we founded called
communitake that's still around
um community initially in its early days
did
the equivalent of remote desktop for
mobile environments
uh so basically the ability to remotely
connect to a mobile device and repair it
and it's a solution that was sold to um
telcos uh mobile operators uh to
have the ability to let's say
have a higher efficiency solution to
repair devices remotely because their
service centers are probably their
their heaviest point of uh of uh
expenditures most of the organization is
people supporting people who have mobile
devices
and we thought if we can remotely
connect to a device and fix it
without having you come to a center or
without even talking to a representative
that long
it would have been very effective we
actually done so we were one of the
first companies in the world to have
that solution and
um it was deployed in several places but
um there was a one incident where me and
shalev were
in some sort of convention and we were
standing in the booth like a million
other startups um
people do and we were approached by a
certain individual from a certain
organization
and he said uh wow this uh this solution
is really cool
um so let me get this straight you ask
for permission as the operator and you
come into the phone and
then you fix it and and we said yes of
course and we started talking about how
much we protect privacy
so the operator can't see your
photographs or your contacts
and we just give him specific access to
the operating system
and he's and at some point we just see
that he's kind of glaring
glaring off and i asked him so
uh what what is it that's interesting
for you and he says well
i was wondering if you can do the
opposite of all that
and uh and me and chella kind of paused
for a second we said
what do you mean he says well i was
wondering if
if you guys can take this solution and
basically get into a device without
asking for permission
and if you think you'll be able to
gain all the information from the device
and being
hungry startup people that we are we
said of course yeah if it's a customer
we'll do whatever is required uh
had zero idea on how to do it and if
it's even possible
and uh we went i remember talking to our
cto who looked at us
and says are you crazy there's no way we
can do this isn't possible
uh there's so many things that are not
even
in the in the right place to have this
ability uh this will require a
completely
different set of people a completely
different set of of
development software tools and we didn't
give up we felt like there's something
there
because you know we started asking
around and
there was nothing of that sort and we
said well if this organization needs it
i'm sure
there's other organizations that might
need it and we started talking to people
from the security
space and they all said yeah this is
considered the holy grail
of uh of intelligence gathering um in
fact at the time
um back in the old days of of
intelligence gathering it was pretty
simple people use their phone just to
make calls and send
sms text messages so if you had a hook
into the operator which
99.9 of operators provide to
intelligence and
law enforcement agencies then you were
you were pretty
you had all the information you needed
you had pretty much everything you need
um if you had a suspect that was on the
phone you can just
ask the operator to listen in or to get
the recordings
and that was that but when smartphones
became smart
and it it's basically a little computer
that has end-to-end encryption
that is using the data stream and not
the voice stream to communicate we all
talk through
digital means today over the internet
right voice over ip and not voice over
to the voice channel
um so there was this global phenomena
of what they consider blind devices
meaning devices that
communicate all the time and agencies
with their regular connection to the
operator
had no idea what was going on so we
figured okay if we can actually solve
this
and help police forces or intel agencies
gain this information
this would be significant so we didn't
give up
we went to our board and it all i
remember
is that it was an extremely
emotional board um we were shouted at
and being the pushy entrepreneurs we are
we were shouting back we said you guys
are crazy
we have to do this we want it to be a
division within community
and the board uh completely refused they
said there's no way that we're
defocusing the company
we have to stay on track and if you guys
want to do this this has to be in a
different company
so we said okay and
we left the company and founded nso
group
and um we got our first couple engineers
that
of course were former 8200
who by the way it wasn't easy at the
time uh
we interviewed a lot of former engineers
from 8200 and they all said you guys are
crazy this is impossible
this is not something that can happen um
but we were adamant and uh we pushed and
pushed and found people who believed in
our vision and we started
to build this solution which um
turned into the basis of nso which of
course today it's much broader and
there's a slew of products and services
that we provide but
uh that was how it started
so and so you know it's a more personal
question
around this area um you know you're
when you're starting this out and you're
creating nso group and
and you're you're dealing with a new a
new type of activity that you know the
world has never even considered in the
last
millions of years that this planet has
existed because you know the
connectivity just wasn't there it just
wasn't
even able to be a question right and one
of the things that i that you know that
i saw in
in the previous interview you're also
mentioning that you know nso group
operates
you know with the law it's you know it's
everything's clean
and and you know everything's
transparent to the extent that
everything's
everything everything that you're doing
is okay yet at the end and you're help
working with governments and
intelligence
is there a part of you that asks some
difficult questions as in
you know we're going to be developing
technology that somebody else is going
to be using
and it is going you know against what a
lot of other companies are trying to
defend
is there even a part of you that that
asks these questions or is conflicted
about that
and and i'm asking as a former you know
8200 engineer
and and and with the context that i know
that nso group
with what you said is doing everything
with the law
so you know i'll i'll be completely
honest
um there's not a lot i can disclose but
i can tell you that
anyone who's worked at nsl or is
currently working in nso and is exposed
to the immense scrutiny and regulation
that nso is exposed to
uh sleeps very well at night
company included um
do we have look at the end of the day
much like cyber security by the way
it's always a balance between um
being 100 secure for example taking your
phone and putting it in a bucket of
water
in that point it's secure right it's
completely secure but it's also not
usable
so there's this balance between security
and usability
you can always turn come to an
organization and say hey let me make you
100 secure
close all the communications there you
go full
security but it's not usable so the same
thing goes for
cyber intelligence it's exactly the same
do do we have the ability to have
control over whatever governments is
using this
for no we we don't much like
other manufacturers of of anything does
a kitchen knife manufacturer
have control if you're going to use that
knife to make a
salad or to hurt somebody with there's
no control once we sell that product
we do everything in our powers and more
i think nso is probably the most
regulated company
not only in this industry but across
several industries
if you go to banking or to other
industries that have heavy regulation
and i think nso is
even more heavily regulated than them uh
so we do everything within our power
to prevent and make sure that this
technology is not misused
of course being this stealthy type of
industry
we cannot always disclose what we do and
how we do it but this is why
we are selling to governments only and
we've done so since inception we have
never sold to anyone who is not a formal
government that was approved
by the ministry of defense and other
agencies throughout the world the united
states one
defense department of defense the
european export control committee
um we're taking uh the regulation that
is
uh let's say put on our shoulders and
taking it even
further by having our own regulatory
leaps and bounds and committees and
people involved that
try and prevent as much as possible
misuse of this technology but
i just want to add that
nothing will ever be a hundred percent
will governments misuse
sometimes but if you know the
amounts of amazing things that this
technology has achieved
the countless lives that it saved the
terrorist attacks that were
prevented the criminal organizations
that were put down
after decades of futility futility
i mean it's all a matter of balance is
it perfect it'll never be perfect but
are we doing our best efforts
one thousand percent okay i think that
that is the key and i remember that i
you know watching a lot of the articles
and a lot of the news and and
the the you know the the arguments
around it i kept thinking yourself it's
more complicated than what people are
describing and of course
there's going to be anomalies and edge
cases but if but the problem is that
you know all the lives being saved and
the terrorist organizations that are
being stopped
that those are not being disclosed on
the media it's not necessarily as sexy
and it's not
and and you know for security reasons
you're not disclosing that
and and so i think that you know that's
exactly i think the perspective that i
also wanted to share that
you know at the end you know from just
thinking of of the goodness that is
being that this technology is being
used for i think that's amazing and now
only now you're on
the different end of the spectrum so now
you're a co-founder of orchestra group
and you're working with companies to
prevent cyber security attacks and
provide and provide these solutions and
so
uh you know thank you for sharing you
know your perspective on the nso group
and i think that's an important
uh conversation to have and just
understanding the complexity and the
side that is not being heard
uh very frequently and and and i have
note and and you know
saying everything that you said i think
that's just remarkable and tell me a
little bit about or about orchestra
group in the context of the greater
vision of
what is happening in the cyber world
today so
orchestra group was actually the birth
child of
our work in founders group so when we
started investing in cyber security much
like a lot of other people who think
they know
we thought that oh yeah we know cyber
we're going to make good investments and
it's going to be great
and we invested in in several companies
uh that we still believe
are fantastic um but we saw that there
is a recurring kind of pattern
that these companies are struggling it
doesn't matter how good the technology
is it doesn't matter
how amazing the team is um
there's a problem in the market space
and we felt that
just by building another tech solution
another tech
company and kind of shoving it into the
market we're not really going to do
anything different and we spent a lot of
time we spent
on orchestra i'd say over two years in
research
uh and trying to understand yes uh
before even opening the company
um we tried to understand where the
problems lie
we spoke to countless csos chief you
know information security officers
of companies from huge like uh the top
five banks in the world
to small and minuscule companies
and the reality was that there's a huge
duality in the market
that has to be addressed if you're a
very well financed and capable
organization
say one of the biggest banks in the
world
then you're spending hundreds of
millions of dollars in cyber security
and you have a team of thousands of
people
just dealing with this day in and day
out and what you do
is you buy everything under the sun so
these companies have
what we call a security stack of
anything between
70 and 150 different vendors which
anyone from any industry will tell you
it's completely crazy there is no way
that these 70 to 150 solutions work in
harmony
there's just no way in fact um some of
the testimonials we got from these csos
were
statistics like for 40 of the stack we
don't even know if it's on or off
let alone if it's working okay but
they're so worried from what they call
the jenga effect so if i pull one of
these solutions out of the stack
they're worried the whole thing is going
to collapse because everything is kind
of
put one on top of the other so
they are in a position where they don't
even know if some of their solutions are
switched on
or off but they just don't want to touch
it because they've been there for 10
years or 5 years or
20 years and let's just leave it in
there and hope for the best
and we can just keep on adding and
that's that's what we call rich people
problem
if you're a small company then you're in
a completely different side of the
spectrum you're basically still in 1996
you're still
just sticking your head in the sand
saying i'm going to be underserved
i'm going to take my chances and
hopefully i won't get hit
i have my antivirus firewall
and some knack maybe a network access
control system
and that's that's about it but the
threat landscape is constantly changing
and what we're seeing
is a massive increase in cyber attacks
from small ones like ransomware to more
complicated and
serious ones like solar winds and the
reality is that nobody can afford to
stick his hand his head in the sand
anymore
um and everyone on all sides of the
spectrum are saying
you know we need something that gives us
a more strategic view we can't just keep
adding
these tiny 20 people company solution
out of brilliant israel and just adding
them on to our stack that's that's not a
viable solution and that's what
orchestra was set out to change
and so what i'm hearing the the clear
distinction here is the idea of strategy
on one hand you can you know aim to go
and bring in these 70 vendors and really
hope for the best without really knowing
what each one is doing but hopefully
you sleep well at night knowing that
there's these 70 startups that are
that are trying to solve these niche
problems
but there is no strategic thinking of
okay are
how do we get a grasp and a handle of
what's happening here right
right so that's what orchestra was set
out to do we said let's try and focus
on an area that we find most hacks come
from which is what we consider left of
bank meaning the
the side before your company gets
attacked
and on left of bang it's it's a lot
about visibility and control meaning i
learning what you actually have in your
network
and controlling it the right way so we
started
looking for solutions that already exist
that were already developed
and trying putting them together
truly not just on a graphic user
interface
uh level but truly at the lowest level
of code
and make them truly work together not
just appear that they work together
which was um quite a challenge our cto
who's completely brilliant dr
jacob buchelson he ran
ibm's a research center in ithaca new
york where watson came from
absolutely brilliant guy had multiple
exits in enterprise software
um he said uh we wanted to draw him in
to join us as a co-founder
and i've known jacob for for over a
decade and he said
this is very interesting this is
something that's truly interesting but
one small challenge we have to own these
companies
and i was like well what do you mean
because we thought we could just
cooperate or
or you know have some sort of sdk
solution he said no no no if you really
want to
kind of weave this code together from
all these different vendors and you
really want it to work you need to have
access to the ip
so it's either we buy them or we find
companies that are happy to share their
ip which obviously
is not very common so we started looking
at this problem
not just as tech people this kind of
it's funny because it relates to the
first thing we talked about
not just being business people who come
from a business environment from
investments from financials
from a variety of areas who are not just
tech
the solution to this problem that the
way we see it
wasn't just a tech solution it was a
business solution
just a one second do me a favor and
let's go back a few sentences before
just about the editing
uh just the editing works out i was
saying
we need direct access to the ip to the
code
of those companies to actually enable
them uh to work together
um i i was saying that it was
a little funny because we started
talking about not being from 8200 and
how does that
uh entail and this is this is a great
example because
uh none of the founders of nso are
former 8200
uh and the the solution is is
not just a tech solution it's not just
let's build the most sophisticated tech
we can do
or find it's it's it's also a business
solution
so the way we did the math was
there were at the time we found the
company there were 1500
funded cyber security companies in
israel and the west coast alone
which is which is absolutely crazy and
if you know
vc statistics that would mean that
there's going to be
i'm sorry to say about 1450
uh bankruptcies within three years now
this is not because these guys are not
smart this is not because these guys are
not capable
or these companies are are nonsense this
is
just because the the the market space
can't absorb
all these small niche solutions
so we said if we have the right funding
we can go out and buy
ready-made technologies that are already
distressed because they can't they can't
compete with companies who are already
there
like i said part of the market is over
hydrated with solution and the other one
is completely dehydrated
so the competition is fierce selling to
tiny organizations
doesn't really get the get the results
that you want because
you're selling to 50 customers each one
of them giving you 5 000
a year that's not really getting you
anywhere and to sell to
i don't know jp morgan or goldman sachs
is incredibly difficult
and expensive so that gap in the market
which
doesn't derive from any training in 8200
but purely from business
understanding and financials we realize
that we can
buy great tech solutions who happen to
have a challenge
in their growth development and put them
all together
and that's what we started to do we we
started acquiring
smaller companies that had a good tech
solution
we started weaving them together and
building uh our own
um let's say single pane you know
unified uh
cockpit you know fine you you can you
can choose your superlative
um but basically this centralized piece
that actually turns all these companies
or their solutions to sensors so they're
they're
instead of being the whole company
they're just a tentacle in a much larger
more
um sophisticated creature which is the
orchestra platform
which we call harmony i'm gonna
i i love that and i'm gonna circle back
now you circled back to the 8200 i'm
going to circle back to my initial
comment of being a cyber security
expert and one of the things that i've
been getting a lot of inspiration in
this show is
is understanding really what it means to
be an expert and a game changer
and i think that going back what i meant
to say is not necessarily that you're
the most
knowledgeable in the in the zeros and
ones and uh
you know you know somebody better than
anybody but it's the but at the end
it's it's whoever makes the biggest
game-changing moves and and whoever is
really disrupting the markets and is
really providing the most value and as
far as i'm concerned that is the expert
in my eyes and and i really appreciate
you coming here i know how busy you are
and i just loved this conversation i
have three short
questions before i let you go to to
running a huge company
and we'll start off going back to your
childhood
when you were a kid what fascinated you
what what really
you know got your blood going whether
it's a subject in school or a passion
hobby
i'll i'll be honest it's atypical maybe
but to me but it's very typical to other
people but computers and machines
i remember completely disassembling and
reassembling
tvs and radios and at some point when i
was slightly older computers
my first computer my second third fourth
i remember my parents
being completely uh nervous and worried
when
they would buy me a computer from the
store and the first thing they do
is look at me just completely
disassemble it all over the carpet
and then try and reassemble it back and
make it work better
uh and fit my my actual needs so i
i remember that very distinctively
amazing and
some sort of inspiration along your way
whether it's a person or
or something that inspired you
throughout your journey
well i mean there's a lot of people that
inspiration to me always comes from
people uh
and what they do but i think maybe
somebody who is with me for the longest
time is my wife
um that despite not being
um she ironically she is from 8200
uh but uh from the from from another
part of it
um but i think my wife was uh kind of a
uh a moral compass and a guide um
she has been alongside me for almost my
entire career
and no matter how hard things can get
and at the end of the day
when you make you know when you do
business it's it's with people
and um
there's there's really an importance to
having somebody alongside with you
to always kind of provide another
perspective to keep you calm and
composed
because people can you know can be
amazing and can be very difficult to
handle
and she has been my backbone
she has been part of the reason that we
arrived to where we are today amazing
and what are three words you would use
to describe yourself
the easiest question of them all of
course yes i i don't know this um
i i remember these kinds of questions
from job interviews that i i didn't do
for about 20
odd years so excuse me if i'm a little
rusty uh three words that describe me
when you think of um what comes to mind
i would say i'm uh i'm creative
um i think it's something that's very
descriptive of me i really like
to try and look at things a different
way
that's something that's i think very
synonymous to me
uh demanding um so if i'm
set to do something uh and the people
around me
are grouping i want things done
a certain way and it sounds a little bad
but it's
it's i think it's kind of a quality you
need to have to survive
as an entrepreneur and
i would say you're curious
um since childhood today it's just
changed
the scale but the desire to learn
new things kind of overcomes every other
thing so if you're worried about
starting your own company because it's
in a field that you were never a part of
the fact that i'm curious about it is
what pushes me forward to
to go and try and do it even if it looks
hopeless even if it looks uh
completely out of character but i i just
really wanna know i wanna
i wanna be involved and see what i can
do with it and
that's the driving force i think behind
most successful entrepreneurs than i
know
thank you very very much this was so
much fun and
and i gained so much inspiration and
knowledge stay safe and stay healthy
thank you thank you
thank you very much
[Music]